[Musique]
léa drucker nous fait partager sa
passion pour salinger jusqu'au 31
décembre 2006 au théâtre de la madeleine
léa drucker aux côtés d'isabelle carré
doublant une pièce d'emmanuel mari dans
une mise en scène très imaginatif et
poétique de zabou breitman blanc raconte
l'histoire de deux jeunes soeurs qui se
retrouvent l'espace de trois jours et
trois nuits pour vivre les derniers
instants de leur mère les deux soeurs se
découvre se parlent et attendre leur
père trois jours et trois nuits
c'est la durée du récit de
l'attrape-coeurs le best-seller mondial
de salinger paru en 1951 trois jours
d'errance désabusé dans new york de
holden caulfield un garçon de 17 ans
devenu le héros emblématique de la
révolte adolescente le 8 décembre 1980
la police arrête mark chapman et vient
d'assassiner john lennon et il est
tranquillement assis sur le trottoir en
train de lire l'attrape-coeur de
salinger qui l'a fait dédicacer le matin
même à l'ex beatles
l'écrivain américain salinger suscite
toutes les sortes de passion voyons
celle de léa drucker
alors effectivement c'est une passion
c'est même plus qu'une passion pour moi
salinger pas ce que c'est c'est même je
dirais que c'est même un tournant de ma
vie je les lui pile à l'âge où il
fallait lire c'est à dire je les lui je
devais avoir 15 ans une amie qui me
l'avait recommandé donc attrape coeur et
c'est ce que j'essaie soupe que j'ai
utilisée pour passer le concours de
l'école de la rue blanche en fait
j'avais choisi un extrait de
l'attrape-coeurs qui me parlait
particulièrement et je suis rentré dans
cette école comme ça ce qui a été
déterminant pour moi je n'avais pas fait
cette école je serais probablement pas
comédienne et je serai peut-être donc
pas là aujourd'hui pour parler de lui
est ce que vous savez du passage que
vous avez voulu très très bien
je laisse donc c'est il raconte dans ce
passage il devait y 2 2 et fun une
rédaction et devait créer une rédaction
sûr il fallait décrire une pièce ou une
maison et il dit l'ennui c'est que
j'arrivais pas à penser à une pièce ou
une maison à décrire comme sera de la
terre avait dit je raffole pas de
décrire les pièces où les maisons
donc voilà ce que j'ai fait j'ai parlé
du gant de baseball mon frère ali mon
frère ali l'avait seconde joueur gaucher
était gaucher et le sujet la description
dans ce camp c'était les poèmes qu'il
avait écrit à l'intérieur et partout à
l'anc revers et les avaient copié afin
d'avoir quelque chose à lire quand il
était sur le terrain et que personne les
lancer la balle est maintenant il est
mort mon frère il a il a une leucémie et
et il est mort alors qu'on était dans le
maine le 18 juillet 1946 vous l'auriez
mais il avait dit et deux ans plus jeune
que moi mais 50 fois plus intelligent il
était terriblement intelligent
donc voila en gros comment comment il
parle des choses c'est à dire ces
aspects de m 2 de mélange de
enfin moi qui me touche énormément de
parler des choses de façon très banal et
en même temps raconté des choses rares
parce que le personnel d'holden
caulfield c'est un personnage
extrêmement sensible aux taux ni très
caustique un peu d'air pur ailleurs un
peu cynique et tout ça mais derrière
c'est derrière c'est une espèce de
sensibilité d'ailleurs et filles
il raconte tout ça il est interné
militants il est temps dans un centre de
commande hier pour dépressifs pas trop
jeune dépressif et c'est vrai que voilà
quand on est adolescent moi ça m'avait
sam avait foudroyé et c'est un bouquin
qui m'a suivi pendant très longtemps que
je n'ai pas relu depuis longtemps mais
c'est surtout aussi l'année des
nouvelles de salinger qui m'avait même
un jour rêvé pour le poisson banane ou
c7 c'est presque ça pourrait être un
super un sublime court métrage si
salinger était pas un fou furieux qui
refusent que c'est un type qui refuse
d'être il a vendu aucun quasiment il n'a
jamais cédé ses droits
tout ça ça pourrait être un spectacle
génial de quelqu'un mais n'a jamais cédé
ses droits je crois c'est quelqu'un de
très est-ce que salinger est devenu
c'est à dire cet homme reclus depuis
1965 à peu près et cet homme qui est
allé vers des vrd philosophie bouddhiste
ou rien et thiery
ah oui c'est ce que ça ce que son
itinéraire vous intéresse je vous avoue
que ça a été quelqu'un que j'ai
tellement idolâtré que j'ai pas eu envie
de lire un truc l'image de salinger
pouvait être un petit peu c'est mon côté
un petit peu
infantile c'est à dire de vouloir garder
des choses dites pas un peu idéaliste
quoi c'est à dire j'ai pas envie en fait
de savoir maman des choses qu'il paraît
effectivement qui pratiquait il était un
peu il est suivi des gourous sais pas
quoi qui qui buvait son urine enfin j'ai
lu ça dans sa vie on grimpe pas bon mais
c'est pas vraiment des trucs qui me qui
m'a qui m'intéresse en fait ce qui me
fascine c'est le fait qu'il ait disparu
il a complètement ismaïla de plus jamais
écrit on n'a plus jamais pu lire des
choses de lui
à partir du moment où ces sorties trahir
il va être un petit peu paranoïaque
c'est peut-être aussi comme sakho des
deux des types comme mark chapman ce
sont maintenant identifie à lui aussi
parce que par son comment vous vivez ça
le fait qu'un adolescent et plus étaient
inspirés qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la
trappe coeur qui peut donner envie de
tuer la colère il a il est en colère
holden caulfield c'est de coller à cette
colère qu'on a d'ailleurs quand on est
adolescent qu'on aille pas forcément
exprimer il a cette espèce depuis cet
anticonformiste aussi probablement ce
qu'il a perdu son frère qu'il aimait
beaucoup qu'il se retrouve pas dans le
monde qui l'entouré ça on peut tous
identifiés à ce à un moment donné mais
est ce que ce n'est pas effrayant quand
on a aimé cette espèce de quête de
l'adolescence éternelle comme comme lui
de terminer les pratiques dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure qui sont ce
qu'ils sont des pratiques qui peuvent
surprendre même choqué oui c'est
effrayant si tout ça est vrai tout ça si
on conserve sa c'est effrayant parce que
c'est d'être un reclus comme ça quand on
a autant de choses à donner en même
temps c'est peut-être c'est lui ou
holden caulfield aussi ça peut que c'est
peut-être un holden caulfield cas pas
mal vieilli mais kaka qui a peut-être
pas supporté
effectivement aussi l'exposition
médiatique je veux dire je crois que des
fois quand on est trop exposé
médiatiquement trop de succès
ça peut tuer l'essence de ce que vous
êtes je crois pour certaines personnes
peut-être je le connais quoi
j'aimerais bien mais je veux dire
j'imagine que c'est peut-être quelqu'un
de sap ça peut être aussi quelqu'un
comme ça qu'a pas supporter ça en tout
cas voilà on quand on a quand on vous
écoute on sent que c'est dommage qu'on
ne puisse pas représentés ou au cinéma
autant au théâtre sa légère parce que je
crois que vous seriez partante aller
nous as à la travée où les nouvelles
leur jour rêvé pour le poisson banane je
pense avoir été géniale mais ça rajoute
un petit quelque chose au mythe moi ça
me plaît assez en fait on va rêver si ça
les joueurs écoutent café picouly qui se
gêne pas il vous appelle ici
[Musique]